please me rain we made up standing for
prayers thank you good evening
counselors I presume you all remember
counselor Graeme Fox who passed away and
before the new year and I'd like to take
a moment to hold silence for one minute
and then after that woman it's silence
I'll pray shall we hold silence
gracious and loving God we thank you for
a counselor Fox for all his influence in
so many different ways yet Lord we pray
for the family that Lord you would
comfort and console them and greatest
Lord as we consider our nation's
struggling with the recent storms we
pray equally for those in distress the
lives and businesses devastated but Lord
you would bring comfort the Lord for
ourselves
as we gather here this evening help us
to set our minds on those things in our
own communities
father we thank you that you have given
us that privilege of actually making a
difference for you making a difference
in our communities so lead us this
evening in all that deliberations and
our decisions guide us by your Holy
Spirit we pray amen thank you everybody
thank you members please be seated
councillor Steptoe
thank you hmm Thank You chairman I just
like to say a few words about councillor
Graham Fox whose name is on the
right-hand board there right at the top
I notice I'm sorry to hear of the death
of the former district councillor Graham
Fox on Boxing Day at the age of 56
following a long battle with cancer gran
was a local councillor lived in great
Wakering for most of his life only
moving away to Cornwall in recent years
he represented the residents of
requiring West Ward as it was then as a
member of the District Council between
1991 and 2002 Graham was one of the rots
the District Council's youngest chairman
serving as chairman of the council in
1998 to 1999 when he was only 35 years
old our thoughts are with his wife and
also his daughters Katie and Lucy who
still live locally thanks Jim Thank You
council Steptoe councillor cut more
would also like to say a few words
germán through you I work with their
counselor Fox when I was first elected I
remember him as chairman here he was
also leader of the Labour group and I
remember some very lively discussions
across this chamber when there were
roughly thirds if you like a party wise
within the chamber and I didn't know he
was ill which is a great shame because
he was he was a nice man and I shall
miss him greatly because we were even
though we were on obviously its sides we
were friends and it said that he's left
us thank you Thank You councillor couple
members a warm welcome to you all
and a warm welcome to the offices of the
council as well on this the full council
meeting on the 11th of February 2020 I
shall take item 1 on the agenda
apologies for absence chairman thank you
apologies have been received in the
office on councillor Burton counselor
mrs. butcher
councillor mrs. Carter and councilor
mill are there any other apologies
members thank you okay any others
members no thank you
I shall then take item two on the agenda
minutes of the meeting held on the 17th
of December 2019 do members approve the
minutes as a correct record of the
meeting
yes thank you members item 3 on the
agenda declarations of interest to
members have any interests to declare No
thank you very much I shall now take
item four on the agenda the medium-term
financial strategy for 2020 to 21 and to
2020 for 25 counts a Steptoe leader of
the council will introduce his item
make the chairman firstly I would like
to thank all of the officers for the
work they've put into preparing this
report I'm sure that members will
realize the amount of work and effort
has had to go in to produce it I'd like
to refer members to the executive
summary on page 4.2 of the report title
for this report sets out rocks with
district councils medium-term financial
strategy which provides a financial
forecast over there over a rolling
five-year time frame from 2020 21 2020
425 he's recommended the residential
2021 gap is bridged and it by an
increase on the council tax that equates
to 4 pound 95 per week or per yeah sorry
beg your pardon but yeah I'm reading
quicker and I can speak per year oh it's
10 pence per week which I worked out
it's aimed at about the same price as a
stick of licorice on a bandy property in
2021
I would like just to highlight the
initially ders initiative fund that is
coming forward it is proposed to create
a new reserve fund of fifty thousand
pound to under pain pin core objectives
and operational of the council but which
will give further flexibility for the
leader to respond to community needs and
react to any emerging issues during the
the year
can I just refer members to a misprint
on page 4.25 item 11
it should read fifty thousand pounds not
fifty pounds further details of the fund
will be supplied to all members the
program also does not include specific
provision for any possible investment
related to the findings of the current
member working groups on carbon neutral
by 2030 car parking and the CCTV it is
acknowledged that on completion in the
year consider and consideration may need
to be given to any of the required
funding relating to these programs which
will be brought back to this council for
approval
based on the correction based on the
correction that I've mentioned I fully
endorsed the report and moved the
recommendation on page four point two
five four point two six items 17 to the
members Jeremy thank you for allowing me
the time to to present this report and
I'm sure that if members have any
questions the portfolio holder for
finance or the one-five one officer will
do their best to answer
Thank You Gemma Thank You councillor
Steptoe Countess of Smith Thank You
chairman I believe what councillor steps
I said he's good news so I'll make no
apologies for an amount of repetition in
what I'm going to say we have the title
MTFs in front of us it's rather a dumb
title but we need to be clear this is
about our budget for the next year these
are plans for the next year but
obviously it's naive to just work one
year in advance so it counts a step to
our outlined we go beyond and into the
future future gauging is not an exact
science so these are our best plans
report in front of you consists of a
hundred and twenty-nine pages the detail
is very much considered many hours of
deliberation have gone into it I'd also
like to pass my thanks to know me and
her team along with the ADEs and their
teams who have provided the substantial
backup to the figures that you see in
front of you but it is the leaders
responsibility a mine for what's been
presented in front of you so what is it
well essentially it is a balanced budget
so budget the reflects good management
good financial management consideration
of risks and opportunities it has some
forward thinking and of course it's good
value for money page 4.2 section 4 has
the highlights and in particular picks
out the council tax a modest rise a
fiver not a month but a year a fiver for
a year
worth repeating just around 10 feet a
week some of the things that it provides
for the continued collection of our bins
with recycling levels that are highest
in the country
provision of housing support that's
facilitated some of the lowest levels of
homelessness anywhere the grant
allocation scheme that helps those in
need and those that give up their own
time to help others and please note that
what page 4.6 6 does have a correction
to come our ongoing playground
refurbishment scheme right across the
district and not to mention car parking
of course not to mention car parking
because yet again there's no increase in
charges within the various tables in the
report
particular figure it's worth mention and
that's reserves sometimes there's
criticism about the level of reserves
that council has so council holds plans
to hold 10% in reserve which is exactly
in line with the sixth recommendation
it's quite right to say that there are
other funds that they are specifically
earmarked reserves to cover longer term
financial planning larger projects items
that are subject to flow fluctuations
and of course our County's
transformation we've recognized the
financial challenges that we face worth
perhaps just reminding members that in
2015-16 the revenue support grant paid
to the council was 1.2 million today
that figure is zero the figure the
figures on page 4.8 show a worst case
scenario of how funding could go but it
provides a flat ground for the
importance of our future planning which
we are doing we do feel that we've
listened to the residents in the
preparation of this report our residents
engagement has raised points that this
strategy addresses our recent peer
review raised some points the
we're giving ourselves the opportunity
to answer with this proposal I have
focused on revenue in what have said
that the report also covers capital as
well in section 9 gives detail of new
and ongoing reserves and does recognize
the member working groups that are
currently formed and that may report
within the financial year and may or may
not require action I do recommend the 15
points to all members listed on page
4.25 and I'm now happy to pass on to
Naomi Lucas to pick out some of the
figures in technical detail thank you
Thank You council Smith thank you yeah
as councillor Smith and the leader said
the council is legally obliged to set a
balanced budget each year and in order
to do that we must match our service
expenditure against the available
funding that we have the proposed budget
for the next financial year will enable
the council to deliver against its
business plan priorities as I set out in
the revised business plan for 2020 2020
3 which is separately on the agenda for
tonight's the local government funding
settlement has been rolled forward for
another year pending the publication of
their comprehensive spending review and
the outcomes of the business rates
review and the fair funding
consultations which are expected later
in the year this has resulted in the
council being given a reprieve from the
630,000 power and reduction in funding
which was expected as a result of the
negative RSD or revenue support grant
adjustment which was proposed for
Rochford despite the relative stability
in funding for the next year there
remains an expected decrease in our
overall funding levels for the council
in future years which coupled with
continued increases in demand for
services and inflationary pressures
gives rise to a protected gap in the
medium term of around 1.2 million by
2020 425 the overall pressures on the
budget for the next financial year
totally just under 750,000 pounds of
which we've identified
250,000 pounds of efficiency savings and
income to offset that this after taking
into accounts changes in funding has
resulted in a gap of 156 thousand pounds
which is proposed as has been set out to
be met through an increase in the
council tax of two point one five
percent which equates to tempi per week
on a bandy property the proposed capital
program for the next financial year
includes provision for routine
expenditure on the council's core
maintenance program as well as the
second year of investment in playgrounds
equipment as agreed and last year's
budget in addition the program also
reflects an indicative costs of the
asset delivery program which was set out
in the outlined business case which was
agreed by full council in February 2000
19 these costs will be subject to review
and potential change as the final
business case is brought forward and is
expected to be presented to Council in
march 2020 the report also sets out the
proposed 2020 Rawdon
capital and treasury management strategy
which has been referred from review
committee and this sets out the
parameters and indicators under which
the capital program work will be
undertaken and the council's cash
balance is managed as councillor Smith
said the council continues to maintain a
general fund balance of around 1 million
pounds or ten percent of its net revenue
budget which is held in order to provide
a contingency for any unexpected or
emergency cross arise in addition the
new leaders initiative fund of 50,000
pounds will give some further
flexibility to respond to any emerging
issues during the year the council's
total level of reserves remains at the
lower end of comparable local
authorities and is not therefore
considered to be excessive and this is
particularly the case given the level of
financial uncertainty that the council
faces over the medium-term members might
like to notice in particular that there
is a proposed drawdown of 1.2 million
pounds in relation to the pension
reserve following the triennial
revaluation and this will be funded from
monies which were specifically set aside
for this purpose
and it's also proposed that the final
year of new homes bonus funding of just
under half a million pounds is used to
create a new reserve which will help
pump Prime the expected pipeline of
transformation projects arising from the
connect program over the next few years
finally I'd just like to note a couple
of Corrections in the report which have
already been alluded to so firstly the
recommendation 11 which should read
50,000 pounds and there's a missing zero
on that recommendation and secondly as
councillor Smith alluded to on page four
point six six of Appendix one the budget
for voluntary grants under the corporate
policy and partnerships line has been
erroneously shown as zero this should be
twenty five thousand pounds as it has
been in nineteen twenty and will be
reinstated by a drawdown from reserves
to 2021 and so yeah if anyone's got any
questions I'm happy that's drawing
Hansen thank you it counts the Smith can
you please confirm that you're seconding
the motion as to step two
thank you members are there any
questions
councillor Wilkinson Thank You chairman
and chairman I've got a couple of
questions before I ask them I'd like to
make it clear that I do understand and I
sympathize with the financial
constraints the council is currently
undertaking I also acknowledge the fact
that a council tax rise it's been
proposed it's minimal however my concern
is that is the council tax rise
necessary and are we spending the money
in the right place and so therefore
Chairman with your permission I do have
two questions happy to obviously ask the
first question but with your permission
if I could ask the second Astra's are we
grateful of course there's first
mentions in the report about the freight
house and its 9.7 that's referred to as
the preferred option but preferred by
whom this program is apparently in its
infancy no decisions have been made and
yet this is now preferred off
for the next 12 months more importantly
for me chairman it lists in the capital
expenditure that we are being asked to
approve this evening 1 million three
hundred eighty two thousand two hundred
and thirty-eight pounds for this this
program so therefore I need to ask is
this in addition to the money which has
already been spent on the consultants
what is it for and why is it nearly five
times nearly five times the next highest
amount of money that the council intends
on spending on anything else in this
budget I noticed also whilst I quote
these figures that there is not a single
penny set aside for the new carbon
neutrality motion which was passed by
this council in 2019 and yet we're being
asked to endorse 1.3 millions on
something which we've not even had sight
off yet
thank you Jim and thank you for your
question yes and the options around the
asset delivery program have been for a
due diligence process in the governance
process processor Investment Board which
sets out a number of options and did
identify and agree the preferred option
through the outline business case as
being the relocation to the freight
house and that's not to say all other
options have been discounted but that
work is obviously still ongoing but that
was agreed by Investment Board as a
preferred option in relation to the
monies are built into the capital
program there are best estimation at
this stage of the year one Capital
respond required as agreed as the
outline business case but as I've
referred to it's prudent to make an
allowance for that
it's Bendix sure in line with our best
estimates but they are still subject to
review following the final business case
so at this moment that's our best
estimate of the capital expenditure it
would be acquired for the first year of
the program but that is subject to
change and that's a slightly separate
proposition to the sort of revenue
budgets in terms of consultancy and
advice we've been taking in order to get
us to this stage
Jemma's or just kind of confirmed know
me so that's in addition to money that's
already been spent this is what we
propose to spend for the next 12 months
as it its its capital expenditure
associated with the build and the cash
flows associated with the with the
program so it's not about the yeah the
revenue costs of actually bringing the
program to fruition and the consultancy
costs we've spent so yeah okay happy
with that Kevin thank you for the
opportunity to our second question and
my question the second question is
probably more directed towards the
leader actually it's regarding
recommendation 11 it's a recommendation
is for a new budget up to 50,000 pounds
we set aside for the leader to spend on
projects and I know he's alluded to it
so far already I should say but what
exactly is this for and a time when
we're trying to achieve other projects
such as carbon neutrality as an example
and I don't understand and I need to try
and understand how we are going to be
asking residents to put the hand in
their pocket to pay more money which I
know some are prepared to do if the
money is going to be going into a pot
that we don't really know what it's
going for I think residents will be
happy to pay towards something where
they're going to see an outcome but at
the moment we seem to be spending money
in some very strange places and I would
be grateful to understand what that is
the funds actually for place cancer step
2 would you like to answer them chairman
I'd like to prefer to refer to Nyami
we'll probably give you a better
explanation than I can thank you mister
okay cancer Smith
the the funding for this particular
initiative has come is being provided
from current year under spend so it's
not new money it's money that has been
previously raised so so it's not
something that's going to be funded from
council tax for the coming year in terms
of what it's for during during the
course of the year
there are various initiatives that come
along there are various budgets that for
whatever reason get close to being fully
spent there are needs that we can't
foresee and perhaps a little bit hard to
admit but sometimes the normal processes
of the council a little bit lumbering
and time-consuming to go through so the
leaders fund is ready ready to hand
reserves to further supplement
initiatives emerging needs or where
budgets have been spent within a year
and as I mentioned a moment ago it's not
new money it's money that's funded from
current year transferred into next Thank
You Council Smith's counsel Wilkinson
yeah Thank You chairman and Thank You
councillor Smith what I would say is
twofold first of all if it's under spend
money why can't that be directed into
something which would then prevent us
from having to put up council tax this
year and secondly as speaking as a
member who sits on two working groups
what a which we've is the CCTV working
group which those members presents in
their working group we'll know we've
only met a couple of times but very very
much at the forefront of what we've been
talking about is money and whether or
not we can financially justify
what we're hoping to achieve money is
the root of everything we're trying to
do and yet we seem to have 50,000 pounds
that we can put to one side as a
contingency and we're being asked for
residents to pay more cash tax on a
German I'm struggling to to ratify them
I can sue Smith Thank You chairman I've
lost the specific pay page reference but
I did load to the working group the brim
with rim play those working groups have
not reported and it would be wrong for
us to allocate money for provision that
has not been reported or or not had a
specific request but there is a clear
acknowledgment within the report that
those committees are going to report in
the ER and that the council is will be
prepared to look at whatever those
reports may say but you cannot force
poor tell what those committees will
report and it would be wrong to make us
to make a financial provision for
something that hasn't happened yet thank
you very much miss I'll try and find
this specifically 9.6 on 4.17
specifically to address that point I'll
let you come back just so one more time
second chef can humans I'm just just
just finally what I would like what I'd
say on that is that's I do acknowledge
the fact that the monies have not been
put aside for those working groups
because yes they haven't reported and
have we therefore got money that if they
were to report within the a bearing of
mind the motion for CCTV has been we've
been told we have to report back within
nine months is that money there I
haven't seen in the budgets if we do
happen to report back saying that we
want it because I can't see that is
[Music]
counter Smith
castle Wilkinson I think your question
has been answered as best possible
counselor mr. hoy Thank You chairman I'm
not aware that we've always had to ask
questions at this point I think we can
also make a statement I may also ask a
question within the statement you should
see it's an interesting Diane's been
reading a few Twitter reports today and
it's obviously budget day for lots of
councils I assume I think there's one
Essex so I expect some of our houses are
quite tired from that I start with the
medium term financial strategy it's
gonna say statement okay it's a budget
for a year and that's what we are
approving the budget for a year we never
approve a medium and MTFs however the
the MTFs yet again is quite sparse in
its detail it's really the current year
and a few projections I understand that
yes it is it can be problematic
forecasting five years ahead
but it it we should be able to forecast
five years ahead to some degree and have
ideas what we might be doing to bridge a
budget gap beyond what we have in here
with a bit more detail for a year on
year so I'm quite disappointed with that
if I move to the actual budget for the
year as I'm just looking at the change
on the previous year and I find it that
quite interesting the original budget
for 1920 was nine point two nine three
million the proposed budget for 2021
he's nine point seven nine two million
icing less interesting that's four
hundred and ninety nine thousand
increase you know proposed to spend for
the year and I thought we were supposed
to be cutting so he seems like we fed
into cart with him you look at page four
point one three the table at the top
you'll say yes the original budget was
knowing
- nine three million but we've actually
managed to spend nine point nine to four
million so I'm wondering where the fifty
thousand pound underspend came from if
we've actually spent 631 thousand pounds
more than our original budget it is
surprising with regard to the increase
in the band equivalent council checks
yes it is two point one five percent yes
thank you there might be considered low
now it is the maximum we can increase it
by without going to a referendum and
again when you look at the table on 4.13
you will see that well we are
contributing 567 thousand pounds into
reserves so that the budget increase
actually increasing reserves it's not
going to pay for services I'm aware
there's some figures within there which
had to do with the new homes bonus but
still even if you discount the new homes
bonus we are contributing part of that
increase to reserves which I believe is
wrong which is why I cannot support the
increase on that basis beyond that I
haven't very much to say on the budget
the the 50,000 pounds leaders fund I I
don't really think it's appropriate that
we should be voting to approve that when
they're going to be given the details
afterwards
odd much have preferred the details on
the fifty thousand pounds before tonight
so we could actually voted on it with
some knowledge of what it's for and how
it's going to be spent and how the
authority to spend it or to move the
funds he's given Thank You councillor
mrs. Mason
Thank You mr. chairman I'm going to talk
slightly differently regarding the
budget to the previous speakers one of
the things that I was interested to hear
counselor Smith say was that he had
listened to residents and we have pages
four one four four and five residents
engagement I think we should be all be
concerned at the level of residents
engagement we have over 87,000 residents
and over 66,000 electors yet in 2018 the
council received a hundred and thirty
six responses in only four of the then
nine categories offered were those that
responded more satisfied than
dissatisfied
despite this poor level of response
similar methods of public engagement
were then used in 2019 with a slightly
increased response of 160 this year
despite the additional use of paying for
social media advertising the level of
response has increased to a mere two
hundred and twenty two of the eight
service areas in the questionnaire fifty
percent were more satisfied than
dissatisfied and of course the reverse
is true fifty percent were more
dissatisfied than satisfied with an
increasing population one would have
anticipated a more meaningful increase
in responses than achieved through any
increase is welcomed the argument could
be raised that most people are satisfied
so they do not respond again the reverse
could be argued we could debate with
equal merit that most residents are
dissatisfied and disengaged and are very
doubtful that their views will be
considered and that they do not consider
the survey worthy of their time
whilst the comments that we have
achieved are welcomed I would trust that
envy of the disappointingly low level of
responses that these are not given an
inappropriate level of waiting which
they may or may not depending in your
point of view appeared to have happened
however the level of public engagement
is just naught point two percent which
is woefully low and does not provide a
meaningful result I therefore would
propose that a working group be set up
with representatives from across the
council's political spectrum to
investigate methods of public engagement
with a few to achieving a much higher
and therefore more representative result
for future years Thank You mr. chairman
sorry I'm figuring that sorry yes cat so
this is about two cats on mrs. Mason you
moving that as a motion in addition to
the recommendations yes yes that was the
proposal or a motion if you say like yes
thank you
counselor mrs. Howard second that
amendments and emotion right we shall
now debate the amendment to the emotion
any questions counselor mr. sparing
Thank You chairman I think members will
remember several years ago we had
numerous road shows for housing projects
housing developments we also spent I
believe the figure was about 13,000
pounds to ensure that every property in
the district received a letter
explaining what our ideas were proposals
for housing one thing another sadly the
response was very similar to what we
subsequently seen thank you chairman
thank you any other questions
counselor mr. Steptoe
Jevon just a couple of points I'd like
to make is that there is currently a
survey going on for the CCTV and I
believe the numbers on that are up into
300s if somebody will correct me if I'm
wrong on that
so after 37 I've got in my mind I don't
know why it seems curious that CCTV
seems to be more important people in
their finances then but that's their
choice of course with regards to the
argument as to whether no response is
they're satisfied or the other way
around I will just simply say that over
the election that we've just recently
had that it appears that most of our
population are very happy with the way
conservatives carry out their work Thank
You Council Steptoe counselor mr. Huy
[Music]
statistics are interesting and I think
the Conservatives may have got 54% of
the vote in the general election which
means probably the majority didn't agree
with them but we leave that there
because we can go on forever about
statistics I think it's good idea
there's we've maybe not last year the
year before but we've in previous
meetings we've had discussions about the
use of the the the feedback we get from
the consultation on the budget and I
know we have looked at briefly in review
about three or four years ago I think
her work a cross-party working group
would be a good way to go with this
because of the CCTV consultation is a
very easy one to so to get people to
react to I think in relation to a budget
and I think it's how social media is
used on accounts the new part was okay
the CCTV one for instance so social
media and it's going on to Facebook
pages and it's a much easier one to do
and I think if we have a working group
to look at the use of social media the
use of how we can get the people to
respond to consultations or to make the
consultations more interesting I think
that would be very useful thank you I
now have Kemp's the hook way please
Thank You chairman in relation to public
engagement in which she's but she's
relates to the motion that these befores
I can see that there's you know some I
think some criticism about how we might
go about public engagement but just just
as a minor point we was involved in a
public engagement thing to do with the
councils Local Plan proposals in my own
village and we had probably twice as
many people turn up to that engagement
or one village than what those responses
we've had to council overall budgetary
policy this year so I think it's about
how we can go about getting their public
involved in this and I think the have if
there's pee on slurs from across the
board we've got a number of ideas of how
they can help with this I think these
would be a benefit to the council as a
whole so I support the motion
Thank You council a Casa Khalil Thank
You chair and as pointed out by both
sides we could discuss whether people
are satisfied or dissatisfied by not
taking a survey
I can only provide input from from
residents we speak to specifically those
of my age and I believe I raise this at
the time with with the council the
survey itself on first time it went out
had a set of answers that didn't match
the question it was asking and also had
an image of the the business plan
instead of text so when people were
looking at this on a device they
couldn't actually take part in a survey
some of the comments we receive are that
these are the type of things that make
people feel like it's token and that
their input isn't actually appreciated
if the time and effort into the survey
itself hasn't been thought through and
thank you councillor canal any other
questions on the amended motion members
Oh Kent
councillor mrs. Mason could I ask you to
repeat your amended motion please thank
you I'll take the opportunity to come
back as well and just saying that a new
proposed business plan says to work
closely with residents communities etc
we don't seem to be doing that at the
moment and I'd like to see us do it in a
positive way so the motion I will repeat
I would propose a working group to be
set up with representatives who across
the council's political spectrum
to investigate methods of public
engagement with the future achieving a
higher and therefore more representative
result on the residents engagement for
the budget for future years Thank You
casa mrs. Mason members you've all heard
that amendment those in favor please
indicate
those against
any abstentions that motion has been
lost to members of course
there was a 15-4 18 against where weed
cancer Steptoe chairman and if I may
what I will do is I'll take the way the
seed of the idea that has been suggested
that we need to find a way of actually
improving things and see what we can do
talk to officers and what have you I
think that's something we'll work on
with the portfolio holders and
what-have-you see we'll see whether
there's anything we can do and perhaps
come back and report later later - Thank
You councillor Steptoe will now continue
to bethe do to make the original motion
as proposed by councillor Steptoe and
seconded by councillor smith and counts
a new port you wish to speak on it Thank
You chairman so I've studied the
apologize if I cover some points that
have already been raised that just goes
to show how important they are and I've
studied the MTFs and I've taken the
opportunity to ask questions of officers
about how the council balances the
budget we know that the council's across
the UK of received funding cuts for
central government despite austerity
being over I'm afraid the same old line
is wearing thin with our residents as
I've spent time looking for the MTFs
I'll touch on just a few items of
expenditure I could not understand in a
time when we're meant to be making
cutbacks making savings watch the
District Council has a policy that
offers a staff bonus for attendance I
always thought it was referred to as a
salary assets that are supposed to
generate the council revenue have poor
accounting records with this I refer to
the old house and rady windmill where
there are no where no office of time is
accounted for in the budget to operate
and maintain these facilities how do you
determine the real value of these assets
and that's financial assets
one thing that has already been spoken
about many times and that's the budget
provision for CCTV and the carbon
neutral by 2030 work and group findings
personally I would have thought budgets
are allocated in advance if the funds
are needed and then returned in the
future this appears to me as there's no
intention to actually carry out any work
of these groups I do not think it's
prudent financial management or
financial planning is it acceptable
practice to not plan if we know or
expect there to be expenditure in the
future moving on to the capital program
the capital program of this council
seeks to provide the council with
transparency over its future spending
plans and to enable effective planning
prioritization and financial management
however part of this plan the asset
strategy which other members have
already mentioned provides very little
transparency to our residents and
particularly members of this council who
are responsible for setting a budget for
this come in municipal gear with the
Investment Board meetings regularly
cancelled
members do not have a clear overview of
how the asset strategy is developing and
the future of many of these of the
assets how can we support an asset
strategy with this level of oversight
which we understand may not be available
to members until March will an amended
mud budget be necessary it's not all bad
though because I actually welcome the
650 8,000 pounds of investment in the
enhancement of the play facilities over
the three-year period but I would like
to say that we should not forget the
youth of the district who perhaps fall
beyond the ages of those play facilities
I've read the MTFs and I've all also
surveyed residents myself via social
media as this seems to be the except
informal consultation
I've spoken to I've spoken to revered
residents an overarching message to me
was more where it needs to be done
within this council to become more
efficient more transparent and less
wasteful on the basis of the capital
program alone I will be unable to
support the MTFs Thank You councillor
newport causa stanley Thank You chairman
there are a few items that have just
been spoken about and this budget isn't
exactly what comes out of the Bank of
England when they are not raising their
rates or you think like it they still
think that we're in dire straits and we
should be saving money I'd like to point
out that has been spoken the residents
are happy with be the rate rise well
actually if you've got your ear to the
ground you'll find out they're not and I
get that all the time and the basis is
that I do think that it is now what has
been voted on as the council have not
taken that interest to the residents
from their local wall councillors and I
find that very disturbing I would have
thought you chairman would have done the
exact opposite however the budget is
there are several discrepancies in the
budget some of which money could be
saved some of which money's being spent
or supposed to be spent for nothing for
absolute nothing and I suggest that
those officers that went through the
budget should go through the budget
again and see where they can save an
awful lot more money especially the
150,000 there is a difference this I
believe you could find quite easy shall
we say cemetery grass cutting there's
one for you that I've been told we no
longer have do that don't ken was have
we got any no we haven't
so why are we putting money to also dog
kennels
that is for something for the officers
who put this budget together to find out
where they can save money that's only
two suggestions I leave it with them and
I cannot support this budget Thank You
counsel Stanley the council wouldn't
Thank You chairman the suggestion that
investment boards have been cancelled
changed because of any fighting on the
part of the assets strategy to report on
time because I think that was the
implication I strongly refute I would
like to pay tribute to the enormous
amount of work that has been carried out
by officers across this council and
members to bring everything about the
asset strategy on time within the
parameters that were originally laid out
it was in December that it was agreed at
the Investment Board that it would be go
through the bidding process it is a
legal process that councils have to
undertake when they're adopting a
program like that I will be reporting
back to Council in March and I really do
want to put to bed any suggestion that
any changes in investment board have
been due to any change in terms of the
program thank you chairman Thank You
council wouldn't carries did you wish to
speak Thank You chair as a member of the
Investment Board it's been quite
interesting listening to some of the
conversations here there seems to be a
bit of a dual standards going on here
when we were talking about some of the
working group of proposals that are
being discussed at the moment
ie CCTV green issues and the likes we
can't put anything in the budget because
nothing has been put forward and yet
when it comes to the asset delivery
program we can put figures in the ERR
but the investment board haven't seen
the figures we haven't seen any of the
figures come back from any of the
inquiries through to the builders
and so we have got a specific sum that
is actually being put into our budget
that no one on the investment board has
bruised I'd like an answer on that
police maybe counselor wouldn't could
answer that for counselor would negate
thank you chairman and the process went
through an outline business case the
outline business case set out in very
specific terms what the arrangements
were and it was voted on at investment
boards the executives and full council
meetings this process actually started
before I was a counselor but of course
I've taken it over as Paul Ferrar
portfolio holder since September and the
I think there may be a little confused
some confusion and the amount shown in
the capital program tonight are about
phasing those were produced figures
within the outline business case because
what we need to accept within that
program is that the rate at which we
spend money may not tie up with the rate
at which we get income from the sale of
any of our assets so it is simply a
phasing issue it is not a capital spend
and we get nothing back so I think that
is hopefully answers the point that
you're making and if it doesn't I'm
happy to take a supplementary carries
would you like to come back yes it
doesn't really answer my question
because all of the figures that have
been put forward to date although we
have agreed an outline business case I
agree on there they are all guesstimate
and we just we have no no figures where
this is the biggest sum that is in our
budget tonight and we are asked to
approve the biggest some based on
estimates as to what we are actually
putting forward here counselor warden
I think it's a bit disingenuous to refer
to them as guesstimates this was a
company that was brought in to advise
the authority on an asset strategy their
figures that came forward were the best
estimates that could be made in terms of
prices the costings and the prices that
we would achieve on the side of the
specific buildings that we were talking
about so to suggest they are estimates
rather implies that figures were plucked
out of the sky they were properly
considered estimates they were
challenged in the various reports but I
think accounts Rives your rather
confusing the fact that we are making a
provision for an amount of money agreed
that it is neatly considerable amount of
money and to carry out the plans when we
actually have the final report from the
bidders and we go through a due process
and to consider that and what we're
doing for this year is actually making
provision to spend money at a different
rate so the rate at which it will come
in from the sale of the assets that we
replace thank you thank you council
warden i'll let you come back one more
time
count Steve's the thing that I find
rather disturbing about this is we're
relying very very heavily on selling the
assets there are some serious questions
on actually the sale ability of them now
we've had professional input on that yes
okay fair enough but the reality of the
situation is that with those some of
those buildings they're in such bad
condition that actually the sale ability
may mean that the only way we can do
that is to drop the prices now the value
is very different to what is the actual
in the end sale price that doesn't seem
to be we seem to be taking carte blanche
the the the the figures that be input to
us at the moment we haven't buy
admission from councillor Woodman we
haven't had our prices back from the
tractors who have been approached so we
don't have confirmation on that yet we
haven't actually at the investment board
seen detailed plans so I'm not sure
quite sure how we can be so certain on
our spend maybe I'm wrong but it is a
point that is concerning me counsel
wouldn't would you like to come back one
last time please Thank You chairman I
think the words carte blanche and
guesstimates are a misuse of words and
there is nothing carte blanche there's
nothing about guesstimates what it is
it's an outline business case where you
start projecting your thoughts and you
have informed people to give you views
on how you move a particular project
through these are not final figures they
are the thoughts informed thoughts of
the consultants that we used
so if councillor Reeves is getting
slightly confused about the original
estimates versus the final figures can I
reassure him please that the final
figures will actually come back to this
council to be approved by members but
please do not get confused by
projections that were brought out of a
consultant a well informed of you
compared with the final figures that
will come back over the next month or
two to this Authority when we have the
actual figures that we're working to
hopefully that answers the question
Thank You councillor wooden I'll ask one
more question and that's from councillor
mr. Howe thank you I just need to come
back on the the asset program again
Thank You councillor Woodson um honestly
very well at the end I think and I think
you've got to the point that we are we
as councillors may be not as involved as
you saying we understand what provision
is and you've stated quite clearly that
the provision has been put in for it but
and the actual cost may be different and
this is what councillor Wilkinson was
saying about the 2030 program and the
CCTV fee program that why can't we put a
provision in and then we can adjust it
to the proper cost that was the only
question of doing I think we came
during the specifics of the asset
delivery program we just try to say
there's a provision for that what can we
do a provision for this and I think that
was the issue there thank you Thank You
councillor hi
I think we've debated this enough now
councillors and I intend to take the
recommendations I shall take them
individually these are the
recommendations on 4.25 and 4.2 six of
the report recommendation one members is
that agreed what are you asking for
councillor hi I'm not asking for record
if I can be Robin sorry can we have a
vote please okay that case you can have
a show of hands please members for
recommendation one those in favor
those against
of course any abstentions
let's carry ten members sorry
mr. chairman could we have the figures
whether folks taken could you give us
the four gang stand the abstention the
figures are at 25 for the recommendation
eight against and one abstention thank
you recommendation to then members those
in favor please indicate
those against any abstentions
recommendation three members are those
in favor so mr. chairman can we have the
result of the votes as you take them
things I'm having to ask each time thank
you we go back to recommend two then the
numbers
chairman's 27 in favor 5 against
there was abstentions yes
abstention votes against ISIL
six extremes right recommendation three
members those in favor
I'm sorry mr. chairman on a point of
order 27 5 & 6 doesn't add up to the
number of members present
yeah German Sonja's going out some
numbers because I'm struggling to hear
okay at least one members voted twice in
that job but there were 27 four and six
abstentions okay to set that up okay
I shall take recommendation 3 again
members those in favor keep your hands
up please
those against
any abstentions right and the figures
are 25 for 8 against and 1 abstention
thank you
recommendation for please members those
who if we don't recommendation for those
in favor please
I was against
any abstentions
and the figures are 25 for one against a
native thank you recommendation 5
members are those in favor
those against
any abstentions the figures are 29 for 2
against into abstention okay
recommendation six members those in
favor
those against any abstentions
the fear thank you right item 7 members
will be a recorded vote
counselor mrs. Belton
for councilor canal abstain counselor
mr. Carter canceled cut more councilor
Dre for Chancellor FG for cancer Reeves
counselor mrs. Gooding Chancellor
Hazelwood canceled a hook way
counselor mrs. hoi
counsel mr. hoy counselor Hudson cancer
you honor cancer Lucas Gill counselor
mrs. Mason counselor mrs. Macpherson
counselor Merrick counselor Newport
counselor mrs. Pavlin counselor mrs.
Rowe counselor mrs. Shaw counselor mr.
Shaw counselor Smith counsel sparing
Chancellor Stanley counselor step turn
councillor Ward for counselor web
answer mrs. Weston cancer Wilkinson
answer Williams cancer Wilson counselor
Wharton
members so a 25 votes for 7 against and
2 abstentions and therefore item 7 has
been approved Thank You members we go on
to recommendation 8 those in favor of
these members
those against
any abstentions
twenty-five for seven abstentions thank
you recommendation nine members those in
favor
those against any abstentions
25 4 & 9 abstentions thank you
recommendation 10 members those four
please indicate
what is unanimous members thank you all
right recommendation eleven members just
to remind members that the figure in the
report is incorrect it should be fifty
thousand pounds as opposed to 50 pounds
those in favor please indicate
those against
24:10 Thank You members recommendation
12 is for noting is that noted members
thank you as his recommendation 13 is
that noted and again in respective
recommendation 14 is that noted members
thank you and lastly in respect to
recommendation 15 is that noted members
oh my apologies members can we without
them please on that one recommendation
15 those in favor
those against
any abstentions
the numbers are
24 for 2 against and 8 abstention thank
you remember that concludes item number
4 mr. chairman if I may ask that now the
officers have gone to the effort of
recording the figures can those figures
please be poked in the minutes thank you
of course yes
members will now take item 5 on the
agenda the Rockford district council
business plan 2022 2023 cancer Steptoe
leader of the council will introduce his
report Thank You chairman it gives me
great pleasure just to say a few words
about the latest version of the council
councils business plan and like before
I'd like to thank the officers for all
the time and work they put in behind the
scenes in preparing this as I'm sure all
members realize these things don't
happen overnight there's an awful lot of
work that happened to get the plan sets
out a strategic direction of the council
and the services we deliver for our
residents the latest version of the plan
has been refreshed following
consultation with members and staff an
addition was included in the recent
budget survey so that residents were
also able to submit their views as a
result of the consultation responses the
revised plan for approval this evening
has been amended to make it clearer and
simpler in the way it explains what the
council will do our priorities remain
largely as before early intervention
maximized our assets and enable
communities are unchanged
however the priority to be financially
self-sufficient has been adjusted being
financially to be being financially
sustainable to reflect the uncertainty
around the arrangements for future
funding of local authorities
as this is unclear
sorry as this is answers as this is
uncertainly be becomes clearer this
uncertainty becomes clearer my teeth
will work through the comprehensive
spending review and government decisions
regarding local government funding then
we renew the business plane in the same
way that we review the MTFs to enable
that they remain relevant the second
page of the plan sets out what we want
to achieve by 2023 and there will be
some more detailed business plans with
smart performance targets to squawk each
item I ask members to support the
revised business plan and I'd like to
move the recommendation on page 5.5 item
I 8.1 the council business plan for 2020
to 2023 be approved thanks Jamie Thank
You council Steptoe councillor ro Thank
You chairman I second that
councillor mrs. Mason Thank You mr.
chairman
I just like to ask a couple of questions
I'm pleased to hear that the business
van will be reviewed because the other
one I don't wasn't aware that it was and
that's a welcome change
can I ask of what frequency and when
because obviously we've got 22 23 so I
would hope that it's not going to wait
until 2023 and I'm also pleased to hear
that we're going to have some targets
and smart targets at that so when will
they be introduced please thank you
countess tiptoe she liked to come back
although I think the Chairman aren't
going to refer to the managing director
on that chairman I think it's probably
prudent to look at the plan on an annual
basis I think that that makes that makes
perfect sense
I mean I think as the as the various
projects make progression then we'll
look at the appropriate targets to apply
to this so you know there won't be a
specific date you know when all targets
will apply to the business plan it will
be as each component of the business
plan make makes progress it can sustain
I think we all know what they are but if
we're having targets let's have them
let's not have them as and when let's
have a date before the targets I mean
I'm a great advocate of targets and I
don't like the smart ones I'm as and
when I don't think it's acceptable thank
you cancer Stanley Thank You chairman I
would like to know if we are going to
get not only targets but how progress
goes along not at the end of a year but
during the course of a year maybe
quarterly or even half yearly if that is
the way the business plan goes thank you
that's a good quarterly is the is the
intention and that's something that new
or miss new only Lucas is looking at in
terms of the the review of performance
counselor Wilson thank chairman all of
the the aims in the business case have
actually very laudable and the problem
that I've got is with the the final page
which is about the outcomes and normally
the outcomes other things that are
different things that are better in the
future and can be measured so my concern
is that we should actually think about
how we're going to measure this before
we start the work not
retrofit the measurements afterwards and
that's important because we need to see
the linkages between the money that we
spend on behalf of our residents and the
services and the improvements that
they've seen and so I've got a final
question really which is do we have the
baseline data already to see whether
we've actually improved this so for
example something like increasing the
number of residents actively
participating in healthier lifestyles
how do we know that we've made the
difference how can we measure that we
must have the data already and that was
a question I would like to ask thank you
well chairman I think as I've already
said that's part of the ongoing review
that Lukas will be carrying out but I
mean I think it's a well-made point and
it clearly is important that we have
appropriate baseline information against
which to measure outcomes so that will
be part of the ongoing work over the
next weave well I shall ask know Naomi
Lukas to say a few words and yeah just
to add to that the members should be
aware that we do already report
performance information quarterly as
part of the financial and performance
monitoring reports which go to executive
each quarter that does encompass a range
of indicators which are nominally mapped
to the current business plan that I
think we accepts that's yeah number of
those indicators are quite historic and
based on old key performance indicators
for example so as as Shaun has said we
are looking at smarter indicators which
could be introduced for the new
financial year which will map and then
correlate more closely to the revised
business counselor hi mr. Jose thank you
Jim yeah been looking forward to the new
business plan I think the other one was
very old and sad and and unpaid never to
be up to have been updated which it was
supposed to have been I'll start off
with the mr. Scranton saying that he
thought this would be updated yearly or
hope this is much more living document
than that
I think when we we think back this is
I'm pleased that some trade
two people into this from the first
draft because I also mentioned about the
2030 projects and climate change should
be included which it wasn't on the
original draft I think if we are having
a report to review committee in March I
believe it is that that could I think we
would be foolish to wait for a year to
feed the results of that reviewing to
this beast explain women could do it
immediately I think a business plan
should be a living document we should be
able to take here we shouldn't be
frightened of changing it or putting
better better things into it and
changing it if we surpass a target we
can put a better target in so I think to
do this just annually would be wrong and
I think we should really look at doing
this much more frequently and certainly
when we get key reports coming back to
the council on something like 2030 we
should be feeding them into the document
and changing it appropriately for that
moving on to the targets there's not a
lot more to say I'm just do you want
reassurance that we're not fitting the
targets to meet what we do it we are
doing the targets now and we're not
waiting for a year to do the targets on
I just mean that reiterated and there
it's just one change I would like to
propose it's just one word which is on
page 5.7 under early intervention most
of these have been checked most of that
what we try to achieve a being improve
for the better
and they offer much Fermin than they
used to be although lacking some figures
which has been raised by the people
however I think the first one can which
I've read it continued so we we will
have continued to work with partners and
communities to ensure our most felt
vulnerable residents feel supported to
live well I would like to propose we
change the word feel to our so they are
supported to live well I can't I think
that's a much better target to have and
I'd just like to propose that one of men
went Thank You chairman
today
sure would you answer that yep
[Music]
I think I think the the key challenge is
is how to measure that as an outcome but
I I don't I don't personally have too
much
i diapered cently would accept that as a
change but it clearly is down to council
you know to determine whether they would
they would also wish to accept that
cancel the councilor Steptoe mind I'm
quite happy to accept that very minor
change within the I'm being shouted down
and free I've got cancer Stanley first
please
Thank You chairman no I mean Doukas
mentioned that you will be reporting to
the executive on the what is proposed on
portal II I do hope is to everybody and
not just to the executive well yeah
executive papers are in the public
domain so they're open to all members to
you and yeah I'll see and consult on
enough I believe all members are invited
now to attend executive meeting if they
so wish council Wilkinson chairman or I
was going to say was I've got a second
counselor whose parcels I don't think
it's been done so so far come back I'll
come back to that councillor ft field
but with the field I think it's for the
person to feel that they're being
supported we're just supporting the
person is us we're supporting them I
don't if that is what was meant in the
actual wording sorry changing that word
completely changes the whole concept of
it
it's the person will feel supported not
that we are supporting them tell me can
I make a suggestion because I mean I
think I think it's it's it's it's a very
good point are you are we measuring what
people feel or what how or how we're
we're put we're performing you know so
why not why not why not why not do both
you know I mean that that would be the
sensible thing to do in terms of the
worthy council ward Thank You chairman I
think it's important to understand the
English language by 2023 we will have it
is future tense
so what we're speaking to here is
residents felt supported to live well I
would support the term felt because you
are future tense and it's how they would
actually respond to it so if we're
actually going to be talking about
residents going forward we're talking of
the future this is actually speaking to
the Future 2023 what we're saying
basically is continue to work with
partners and communities to ensure our
most vulnerable residents felt supported
to live well felt supported as opposed
feel wrong tense members we have a
proposal and a seconder on the floor I
propose put that to the vote
councillor mr. high can use once again
explain the exact change you require
please
Chairman on comments I take on board
counselor wants comments about the use
of the English language and I understand
that he's also a comment on the word
field which was incorrectly used as well
so I'm perfectly happy to to withdraw
the motion I didn't put a new motion
which would state that the word should
be residents
I've been haven't filled and have felt
that they have been supported if you
know ii defer i think it as if he said i
think it's a fairly minor point and i'm
just trying to get something which I
feel is measurable and people can
comprehend into this Thank You counsel
mr. Howe do you have a seconder for that
change can smoke why
sorry counselor hi can we just be clear
on the wording I'm just got counsel hi
I'm just gonna read it so there were do
you your the moment the amendment you're
proposing is continued to work with the
partners of communities to ensure our
most vulnerable residents have felt
supported to live well
so it's have felt supported okay those
who favor of that change their members
whose indicate those against any
abstentions
is that an abstention because Hazelwood
okay that has been passing members thank
you
notwithstanding that members there is
one recommendation it is that the
council's business plan 2020 2023 be
approved is that approved members yes as
amended of course members thank you
members that's the last item on the
agenda and that's the case I closed a
meeting at 8:58 thank you very much
members please be upstanding for the
chairman